septembre 2014 à l'issue des 24 heur du
M le GMT 94 devient Champion du Monde
d'Endurance avril 2015 de retour dans la
S Christophe gu et ses joyux Dr sont
prêt à en découdre à
nouveau c'est une super équipe les TR TR
c'est r Foulou sentend super bien et et
c'est SR c'est un plaisir d'être avec
eux un
plaisir r Fifi loulou plus connu sous
les nom de David sheeka et Kenny foret
pilote au Liftin fidèle au timyama
depuis 2010 fidélité récompensée par ce
qui reste l'un des plus gros titres de
sa
carrière pour Kenny c'était super parce
que il le méritait il a il a tout donné
il a modifié son c le pilotage il a il
s'engage
énormément engagé sur tous les fronts
Kenny foret vient de remporter auain une
manche du championnat de France de
vitesse avec la nouvelle moto c'est bon
pour le capital confiance place
maintenant à l'endurance et au 24
première étape des championnats du monde
un titre à défendre et un succès
espéré c'est vrai que si on peut
accrocher une victoire avec la nouvelle
moto ça serait quelque chose
d'extraordinaire maintenant voilà faut
faut faut mesurer ses objectifs on a
quand même beaucoup de travail la moto
est arrivée assez tard donc on a quand
même beaucoup de chance qu'elle soit
très bonne mais nos concurrents sont
très performants et et pour le moment il
nous en manque un tout petit
peu performant et nombreux 58 équipages
au tour des champions du monde au départ
de cette course temps convoitée le
samedi 18 avril à
15h